[Musik]
vorerst keine impfungen mehr mit
astrazeneca auch deutschland will
weitere untersuchungen abwarten
die entscheidung ist ein schwerer
rückschlag für die impfstrategie
krisenstimmung in der cdu und nach
schweren verlusten bei den
landtagswahlen im südwesten sprich die
union von einem weckruf sind das
optionen auch für berlin nach den wahlen
führen grüne spd und fdp rückenwind
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sievers die welt an diesem
montag in einer neuen woche guten abend
in allen sport nachher in der sendung
mit kristin otto ich grüße sie genannt
es ist eine nachricht heute nachmittag
mit erheblichen folgen ein schwerer
rückschlag für die impfkampagne in
europa
nach einigen anderen ländern stoppen
jetzt auch deutschland und frankreich
vorerst alle impfungen mit astrazeneca
der bundesgesundheitsminister sagt das
sei eine vorsichtsmaßnahme
nach einer empfehlung des
paul-ehrlich-instituts dass weitere
untersuchungen gefordert hatte es gibt
in einzelnen fällen berichte über
gefährlicher blutgerinnsel
möglicherweise im zusammenhang mit dem
vakzin christoph festival halb wir haben
nachmittag kurz nach der eilmeldung auch
im impfzentrum erfurt legt sie den
betrieb lahm
impftermine platzen alles plötzlich
anders und die betroffenen rat bis
fassungslos deutschland weiter das finde
ich nicht in ordnung das geht so nicht
warum so ein drastischer schritt
gesundheitsminister sparen erklärt
hintergrund sind neu gemeldete fälle von
thrombosen der hier in wien die in
zeitlichem zusammenhang mit einer astra
zenica impfung stehen
ein impfstoff unter verdacht sieben
fälle bei 1,6 millionen impfungen in
deutschland die quote muss geklärt
werden entschied das
paul-ehrlich-institut es gibt solche
fälle auch ohne impfung in der
bevölkerung und mit diesen neuen schäden
ist diese anzahl über diese schwelle
übergetreten
nicht auszuschließen ist dass wirklich
die ursache in der info glied gefahr und
nutzen die alte abwägung beim impfen was
da heute entschieden würde
manche halten es für einen fehler die
prüfung ohne aussetzung der impfung wäre
wegen der seltenheit der komplikation
besser gewesen in der jetzt fahrt
aufnehmenden dritten welle
während die erste impfungen mit dem
astra zeneca impfstoff lebensretter der
fehlt jetzt bis auf weiteres vielleicht
ein paar tage vielleicht länger das wäre
ein echtes problem
dementsprechend das astra zenica eine
ganz ganz wichtige säule in unserem ins
programm
vor allem weil dieser impfstoff eben
halt auch von aus ärzten betriebsärzten
ohne probleme vertieft werden kann
und wenn wir jetzt in anführungszeichen
nur noch auf die peripherie zurückfallen
dann wären wir nicht tun bekommen dass
alles über impfzentren abzuwickeln und
dementsprechend wird sich die breite
massen impfung deutlich verzögern
impfzentrum altötting in bayern 5 uhr am
nachmittag und es wird weiter geimpft
aber nur noch bei astrazeneca ausruf ist
heute nicht besser geworden
jascha dollar banerjee in berlin damit
dürfte das vertrauen in astrazeneca dass
bei manchen ja ohnehin nicht besonders
ausgeprägt war jetzt dauerhaft am ende
sein
hat denn dass die politik angesichts der
wichtigkeit dieses impfstoffs für
deutschland mit einkalkuliert also jens
spahn hat zumindest in der
pressekonferenz sich sichtlich darum
bemüht schadensbegrenzung zu betreiben
indem er sehr oft betont hat dass der
impfstoff nach wie vor unter dem strich
für die meisten ungefährlich sei also
erscheint sich des risikos bewusst zu
sein
wichtiger scheint ihm momentan zu sein
zusätzliche zweifel am astra zeneca
impfstoff so schnell wie möglich
auszuräumen
denn man muss ja sagen dieser impfstoff
ist vorbelastet er war schon in der in
der zulassungsphase in der kritik weil
die datenlage da nicht ganz eindeutig
war oder schlechter war als bei anderen
impfstoffen
dann gab es das hin und her um die frage
ob man ihn für über 65-jährige zu lassen
kann oder nicht also da waren ja vorher
schon zweifel da das vertrauen war nicht
wirklich groß und da will nun sparen
offensichtlich jetzt in die offensive
gehen transparent testen lassen und
aufklären der die deutsche stiftung
patientenschutz sagt übrigens das sei
genau der falsche weg und wirft ihm vor
damit einen flächenbrand auszulösen
gemeint ist vermutlich dass man eben die
zweifel die jetzt dann zusätzlich doch
aufkommen durch diese testung durch
diese überprüfung am ende möglicherweise
nicht mehr loswird wer dann am ende
recht hat das sehen wir erst wenn der
stoff wahrscheinlich wieder zugelassen
wird
vielen dank für diese einordnung und
willkommen ein bisschen später in dieser
sendung noch mal zurück zum thema corona
schauen jetzt aber erstmal auf die
landtagswahlen gestern und ihre folgen
es war ja der staat in einem
superwahljahr
zuerst baden württemberg da sieht es so
aus die grünen legen zu auf 32,6 prozent
die cdu mit verlusten 24,1 die spd bei
11 prozent die fdp bei 10,5 die afg
verliert jetzt 9,7 prozent und dann
gucken wir über nach rheinland pfalz
dort die spd vorn mit 35,7 prozent die
cdu auch hier mit starken verlusten 27,7
die grünen legen zu 93 und auch hier
verliert die afd deutlich 8,3 prozent
die fdp bleibt bei 5,5 und die freien
wähler 5,4 prozent vor allem bei der cdu
schrille nach diesem wahl haben die
alarmglocken auch und gerade im hinblick
auf die bundestagswahl frank buchwald
berichtet schwarzer tag heute für die
cdu der vorsitzende kann beim amt muss
für eine doppelte niederlage gerade
stehen
das wahlergebnis der landtagswahl ist
für die cdu enttäuschend es gab dafür
verschiedene gründe in der zdf-sendung
was nun spricht laschet über
versäumnisse la corona politik und
masken skandal dass wahl-debakel
versteht er auch als weckruf
die bundeskanzlerin tritt nicht mehr an
eine neue mannschaft kommt geht in einen
wahlkampf der offen ist in vielerlei
konstellationen und insofern ist jetzt
jedem klar wir müssen kämpfen wir müssen
für unsere ideen werben in der cdu
herrscht seit gestern alarmstimmung
offen noch immer die k frage wer für die
union im september in die bundestagswahl
csu-chef söder dem ambitionen nachgesagt
werden gibt sich kämpferisch
es gibt theoretisch mehrheiten jenseits
der union
deswegen ist der glaube oder die
hoffnung 1 2 prozent mehr oder weniger
sein egal
die union stehe auf jeden fall den
kanzler diese überlegung ebenfalls ist
seit gestern abend nicht mehr zu 100
prozent sicher ein kanzlerkandidat
allein aber wird die union kaum retten
warnen experten
wichtiger als die person ist natürlich
die frage welche erzählung damit
einhergeht was ist das
alleinstellungsmerkmal was wird die
programmatik sein eine neue erzählung
jedoch jenseits von weiter so gar nicht
so leicht für die cdu nach 16 jahren
macht und merkel
was nun herr laschet der cdu-parteichef
stellt sich den fragen von bettina
schausten und peter frey direkt nach
unserer sendung hier andere parteien
sehen sich nach den ergebnissen gestern
im aufwind allen voran die grünen die
fdp aber auch die spd
interessant wird der blick auf mögliche
neue koalitionen in rheinland-pfalz
ließe sich die bestehende ampelkoalition
fortsetzen mit spd grünen und fdp
und auch in baden württemberg ist neben
der aktuellen grün schwarzen koalition
eine ampel möglich das heißt eine
regierungsalternative ohne die cdu was
das für deutschland insgesamt bedeutet
patricia wiedemeier dass die union ein
abonnement auf das kanzleramt hat das
schien lange klar
doch nach ihrem wahlerfolg in rheinland
pfalz träumt nun die spd davon den
kanzler zu stellen
jetzt als eine regierungsoption ohne die
union gebe eine ampel das wahlergebnis
ganz besonders durch das in
rheinland-pfalz verleiht der
sozialdemokratischen partei insgesamt
flügel
es gibt die möglichkeit eine
sozialdemokratisch geführte regierung zu
bilden und es gibt mehrere möglichkeiten
das zu tun und das ist ein gutes zeichen
für unser land flügeln um abzuheben so
die ersten reaktionen in berlin denn die
spd liegt seit monaten in umfragen im
bund hinter den grünen die bei diesen
neuen farbspielen gar nicht erst
mitmachen wollen
manch andere herren berufen sich schon
mal aus um zum kanzler aus aufgrund der
ergebnisse in den ländern aber das ist
nicht unsere art politik zu machen
die haben immer gesagt als wir
festgenagelt wurden bauwerke h werk ist
doch völlig klar es wird schwarz-grün
sie können sich noch aussuchen wollen
sie lieber lastet oder syrer haben wie
es überhaupt nicht klar alles ist
möglich in diesem jahr und eine dieser
theoretischen möglichkeiten ist eben die
ampel die fdp sieht sich jedoch
inhaltlich der union wesentlich näher
als den herren kühnert und hofreiter
wenn es um die harten entscheidungen der
nächsten jahre geht weil wir einen
modernisierungsstau haben und weil wir
die folgen der pandemie politik dann zu
bewältigen haben werden und so
spielerisch über farben zu sprechen und
nicht über die die inhalte die umgesetzt
werden müssen ist jedenfalls etwas wo
wir uns nicht gerne beteiligen möchten
ob schwarz grün rot rot grün oder nun
die ampel
klar ist nur für eine solche koalition
im bund gibt es derzeit in den umfragen
gar keine mehrheit
theo koll bringen damit dazu theo guten
abend auf welche punkte müssen wir denn
jetzt in den kommenden wochen besonders
achten im berliner politbetrieb central
wird sein wie die union jetzt mit ihren
absehbaren schwachstellen umgehen wird
vor allem mit der bisher schleppenden
pandemie bekämpfung den zorn bekommt
hier vor allem die cdu ab selbst die csu
tut so als sei sie nicht beteiligt und
haut drauf wenn die tests und
impfstoffversorgung der menschen nicht
bald und deutlich besser wird wenn die
dritte welle dann das land erneut lahm
legt dann dürften die werte der union
weiter runter gehen und dann öffnen sich
wirklich die von der spd heute schon
propagierten mehrheiten diesseits der
union noch reicht es dafür nicht aber
noch ist auch nicht klar mit wem die
union als kanzlerkandidat antritt und
auch das ende der ära merkel ist noch
gar nicht eingepreist in den unions
umfragen es wird also ein noch
spannenderes war ja als eh schon gedacht
vielen dank für diese analyse heute
abend theo koll in berlin
und dann schauen wir doch jetzt noch mal
ein bisschen genauer darauf was sich da
in baden württemberg getan hat
jahrzehnte lang war das ein stammland
der union jetzt eine etablierte hochburg
der grünen kandidatin der partei von
winfried kretschmann eroberten so viele
direktmandate wie noch nie dabei haben
sie offenbar auch konservative wähler
für sich gewonnen anna wassberg eine
kleine erdgeschosswohnung zur untermiete
beim kreisverband das ist felix herkens
wahlkampfbüro alles noch ein bisschen
provisorisch er ist der erste grüne
überhaupt der jemals in pforzheim das
direktmandat für den landtag holte der
wahlkreis über jahrzehnte fest in
konservativer hand ich denke wir grünen
haben einfach aufgezeigt dass kein
widerspruch gibt beispielsweise zwischen
wirtschaftspolitik und ökologie wir
denken die themen einfach zusammen und
es muss man heutzutage auch seid ja dann
legen die grünen in baden württemberg zu
auch bei den direktmandaten vor zehn
jahren noch neun 2016 schon 46 jetzt 58
auch in seinem wahlkreis hat jetzt ein
grüner das direktmandat cdu urgestein
willi stächele muss nach 30 jahren
abgeben
immerhin reicht seinen stimmenanteil um
weiterhin im landtag zu bleiben
gesamtstimmung untergegangen bohne
pandemie wäre es möglich gewesen zu
zeigen
druckt das sind unsere zukunft 71 23 so
müssen wir das land würde lieber vorne
bringen
die schwäche der cdu nicht nur auf
corona zurückzuführen
auch winfried kretschmann ein
konservativer grüner kostet sie stimmen
und für viele scheint die cdu nicht
modern genug zu sein so schnappt sich
dieses mal in kehl ein grüner das
direktmandat klimaschutz innovationen
zusammenhalt und deswegen sind wir nicht
die neuen konservativen aber wir
repräsentieren die themen der zukunft
und die themen mit den richtigen knöpfen
gepaart das ist unser erfolg bisher
besonders in baden württemberg doch
durch den erfolg hier hoffen die grünen
auch auf rückenwind für die
bundestagswahl im herbst
so und jetzt wie versprochen in dieser
sendung zurück zur krone anlage in
deutschland impfungen sind nach ansicht
von experten ein entscheidender grund
dafür dass die zahl der pandemie toten
in deutschland zurückgeht während die
fallzahl weiter nach oben gehen
aktuell meldet das robert-koch-institut
6604 corona neuinfektionen innerhalb von
24 stunden das sind 1593 mehr als
vergangenen montag
47 menschen starben in verbindung mit 19
die bundesweite ins ident ist gestiegen
auf 82,9 und immer mehr in den fokus
rücken die zahlen bei kindern und
jugendlichen die deutlich zunehmen
sehr rasant nennt das
robert-koch-institut den anstieg bei den
unter 15-jährigen die ursachen sind wohl
vielfältig die ausweitung von
schnelltests auch bei kindern ohne
symptome könnte eine rolle spielen warum
diese altersgruppe nun stärker in der
statistik auftaucht vor allem stehen
aber immer mehr geöffnete schulen und
kitas im verdacht das virus entscheidend
zu verbreiten
volker check der erste schultag nach
drei monaten zwangspause er beginnt in
der turnhalle des drehs der gymnasiums
mit einem schnelltest der arbeiter
samariter bund hilft der neustadt
rumpelt mit der rückkehr von 240.000
schülern der weiterführenden schulen war
sachsenweit eigentlich eine testpflicht
vorgesehen die ist jetzt aber ausgesetzt
es gibt nicht genug tests für alle die
schule versucht das beste daraus zu
machen
die schüler seien sich ja dann
vermutlich ab der kommenden woche selbst
testen
das ganze soll einmal die woche
stattfinden es holpert auch in
brandenburg hier in potsdam haben die
eltern erst ende der woche aus den
medien erfahren dass es ab heute
schnelltests auch für grundschüler gibt
die lehrer haben den kindern tüten für
die spuck tests mit gegeben viele eltern
fordern weitere sicherheitsmaßnahmen
plexiglas trennscheiben mobile raum
luftfilter
das sind auch alles sachen die schule
sicherer machen können die aber
überhaupt nicht angepackt werden wir
konzentrieren uns jetzt nur auf tests
und dürften bis der arzt kommt
das ist uns über noch zu wenig überall
wo die inzidenz drei tage lang über 100
liegen müsste die vereinbarte notbremse
greifen und öffnung schritte zurück
genommen werden mahnt der
regierungssprecher insbesondere auch
ganz besonders auch in der jüngeren
bevölkerung kein rückgang mehr der
belegung der intensivbetten das sind
gute entwicklung auf die wir alle
zusammen reagieren müssen die
infektionsrate in den nächsten tagen wir
zeigen ob auch der schulbetrieb weiter
geöffnet werden kann
und jetzt unser nächstes thema es ist
eine der grössten tragödien dieses
jahrhunderts der verheerende kriege in
syrien dauert jetzt zehn lange jahre
mitte märz 2011 beginnen die proteste
viele demonstrieren für ein besseres
leben für die freiheit und gegen syriens
machthaber baschar al assad
der ist heute immer noch an der macht
sein land am boden schätzungsweise
600.000 menschen haben bislang ihr leben
verloren in den bürgerkrieg etwa zwölf
millionen menschen sind geflohen und das
leiden geht weiter jeden tag mehr von
uli gack zerstörung und kein ende
millionen syrer sind ausgebombt
vertrieben auf fremde hilfe angewiesen
lebensmittelpreise explodieren das
letzte geld ist aufgebraucht ausgegeben
damit wenigstens kinder durchkommen
sie hat noch brut ergattert viele andere
hier werden leer ausgehen video aus
aleppo lange hart umkämpft jetzt wieder
regierungs gebiet massenandrang an einer
bäckerei des welternährungsprogramms der
vereinten nationen
12 4 millionen leute brauchen
nahrungsmittelhilfe wir unterstützen 5
millionen leute und erst noch mit einem
30 prozent reduzierten
nahrungsmittelpakete weil das geld nicht
reicht
zehn jahre krieg in syrien millionen
hausen in lagern hungern
egal auf rebellen oder regierungsseite
so bitter wie jetzt sagen viele war es
noch nie
wir sind arm es gibt nichts aus unseren
häusern von unserem land mussten wir
fliehen wir sind erschöpft
die flucht hat uns gebrochen wir haben
nichts wovon wir leben können
syrien in not zunehmend erreichen uns
bilder unterernährter kinder mit
mangelerscheinungen die bleibende
schäden erleiden und ärzte die klagen
wird sie nach zehn jahren krieg nicht
mehr für die menschen tun können wenn
sie etwas für die menschen in syrien tun
wollen das geht über das aktionsbündnis
katastrophenhilfe stichwort zdf nothilfe
syrien
hier ist die bahn de 6 5 104 106 100 104
106 100 alles auch noch einmal
nachzulesen auf spenden zdf de und im
zdf text auf seite 8 190 und damit sind
wir an diesem montag bei kristin otto
und das heißt sport
zwei themen zuerst segeln es geht um die
älteste trophäe der sportwelt eine
verschnörkelte silberkanne die die
siegerkuh beim traditionsreichen
americas cup erhält kommende nacht
könnte es wieder soweit sein wenn ja
wenn titelverteidiger neuseeland zwei
weitere siege einfahren würde
neuseeland mit den roten segeln hat in
der nacht die siebte wettfahrt souverän
gewonnen und jetzt gegen italien mit 4
zu 3 in führung gegangen im achten
rennen dann ein drama bei schwachem wind
ringt neuseeland nach einem fehler
minuten lang darum wieder fahrt
aufzunehmen
italien zieht davon führt mit fast
viereinhalb minuten da der alte luna
rossa das gleiche schicksal windlauf
stillstand die neuseeländer fliege auf
den auslegern den falls die die boote
aus dem wasser heben wieder vorbei und
gewinnen mit fast vier minuten vorsprung
was für ein rennen eines das sicher in
erinnerung bleibt ist das war eine
unglaubliche aufholjagd von den jungs
hier an bord 5 zu 3 führen peter berling
und seine crew haben beste chancen den
titel für neuseeland in heimischen
gewässern zu verteidigen
in knapp zwei wochen am 28 märz
saisonstart der formel 1 der auftakt der
23 wm läufe diesmal in sakhir beim
großen preis von bahrain
die testfahrten sind beendet es wurde
sehr viel getüftelt um die optimale
abstimmung zu finden
dasselbe in grün oder alles noch
schlimmer als bei
ra sebastian vettel stoppen auch bei
seinem neuen cms den martin immer wieder
technische probleme keine chance sich
umzustellen auf eine neue lenkung im
völlig neuen auto viele
trainingskilometer die fehlen vettel
vorletzter in diesen trainingstagen
langsamer nur sein teamkollege vordere
plätze kaum vorstellbar derzeit auch für
mich schumacher im team hs einem des
schwächeren teams doch bleibt dem
immerhin die freude auch seine formel 1
premiere natürlich gespannt darauf
nämlich nicht viel mehr ich mir
sicherlich sehr sehr großen grinsen
rausgehen mehr draußen bin ein zwei
lehrjahre braucht eben auch ein
schumacher die sollte man ihn können
ein schneller sport in jeder hinsicht
vielen dank herr sind valiant wirklich
so da kommt man zum wetter ist es kalt
geworden und es bleibt kalt diese woche
geht winterlich weiter und bringt
neuschnee alle details gleich von katja
honnef ich empfehle ihnen sehr dass
heute schon mit dem kollegen claus
kleber um 21.45 und wir sehen uns sehr
gerne morgen wieder wenn sie mögen
bis dann aber erst ihnen allen einen
angenehmen abschluss
[Musik]
er nahm meine damen und herren das wird
eine kalte woche denn zwischen diesen
teams über südosteuropa und dem hoch bei
großbritannien kommt der wind aus
nördlichen richtungen und damit wird es
bei uns kalt das bedeutet es fällt
schnee
und auch schwierig besonders im
erzgebirge aber auch am alpenrand
schneit es ergiebig sonst sind etliche
schnee und schneeregen schauer unterwegs
und das ist auch heute nacht so da
schneit es am kräftigsten an den alpen
die schauer sonst lassen mehr und mehr
nach die temperaturen liegen bei +4 grad
im emsland oder auch am niederrhein und
sinken bis minus zwei grad am alpenrand
es ist also fast überall kalt genug für
glätte auf straßen und gehwegen
die höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen im
osten ähnlich wie heute bei 2 bis 8 grad
im westen bei 7 bis 10 grad ein kleines
bisschen bilder und auch morgen schneit
es noch kräftig weiter zum einen dem
erzgebirge aber auch am alpenrand sonst
sind viele schauer unterwegs und am
freundlichsten wird es morgen an den
küsten von ost und nordsee aber auch
richtung lüneburger heide wendland und
als mark und in den nächsten tagen geht
es mit schnee und schneeregen weiter und
am freundlichsten es ist immer in
norddeutschland bei temperaturen von 1
bis 9 grad
schönen abend noch